you have always said that you don't want
the big state companies to be buying the
newly privatized ones so how could you
you wouldn't allow that could you you
spoke just now over state-run companies
Ross near strictly speaking isn't the
state company let's not forget that 19.7
percent of it belongs to DP which by the
way is a British company British
subjects who you essentially you're also
you may have more control over Rosneft
and the Teresa may has over over VP yes
maybe we have more control but strictly
speaking it's not a state company I
wanted to say that I think this is a
clear fact 19.7% belongs to a foreign
investor nevertheless given that the
controlling state belongs to the state
probably it's not the best option one
company under state control acquires
another purely state company this is one
position the second is in the final
analysis it's important for the budget
who gives more money in the auctions
that should be organized as part of the
privatization process and then the sense
we can't discriminate against market
participants not a single one of them
but it's not relevant at the moment as
the government decided to delay Bosniaks
privatization that's gone but on the
question of privatization you said back
in 2012 that you wanted to expand
privatization you've had a difficult
time of it why is that not worked and is
there a case why does the Russian
government need to own 50% of these
companies maybe you could sell more
ah he's coming
the Russian government has no need for
such large stakes I'm certainly intend
to carry out our plans the question is
not where we want to or not
it's where it makes sense and what
moment in time philometor talita
Brezhnev lavinia on the whole this makes
sense risk on one point as well from the
standpoint of structural changes in the
economy the state really in perhaps to
be the padishah marine key but in the
polling market even from the point of
view of fiscal interest doesn't always
make sense
so we take from the standpoint of
privatization and the state's gradual
the role from services is unchanged it
remains unchanged by the way you
mentioned Ross net we are busy preparing
to privatize part of our Ross let's take
itself this is the best confirmation
that we haven't changed our fundamental
for example we sold the stake in one of
the world's biggest diamond produces in
Russia our Rossa we are working the same
way in other end so we aren't changing
fundamental position it's just not in my
shoes as we say you make a fuss that is
really and we must do it immediately at
any price we should do it with the
maximum effects for the Russian state so
you would do Rosneft this year you would
come sell those shares in Rosneft this
year you hope we are preparing for this
deal this year I don't know if the
government can prepare
and the deal together with the
management of frost news itself I think
that we should be talking about
precisely such investors but we are
preparing and planning to do the deal
this year and do and do again just to
push you on that 50 percent you would
you be happy in a world where the
Russian state had less than 50 percent
of these big companies we don't see
anything horrible in this you know I
remember that we had once a company I
one name it now but 50% of it went to
foreign shareholders for analysis the
contributions to the federal budget tax
payments increased several times
immediately and the company's efficiency
didn't deteriorate at all so from the
viewpoint of the state's interests the
and interests of the state from the
standpoint of its fiscal interests we
have positive from the negative
experience